let's make a little nature's candle out
of rock
get some rocks yeah okay danica patrick
and i
are in the heart of the vast utah desert
she doesn't know it yet
but danica just found us something to
eat
don't make me eat a scorpion oh god
look at this guy scorpions they can they
can kill you enough on them to kill you
so
the other i mean what we could do is
actually go and actually look look for
these
if we found that under there we try and
turn over a few more see if we can find
a couple of extras
make a little scorpion kebab you
dispatch it
no no this doesn't mean yes
don't let him get away once you go in
done okay
so that's one try and get a couple more
it was difficult to take the knife and
drive it into the scorpion's head
but this is survival and so
you do what you have to do okay
scorpions let's find some more
the stinger of a scorpion's tail is full
of neurotoxic venom
that can cause extreme pain and in some
cases paralysis
and death however when eaten nearly half
their body
is good protein if we remove the stinger
and pincers
and grill it just right it just might
taste like something you'd want to eat
but we're going to need more than one to
keep us going so we're going hunting
okay no scorpion there
this is a perfect place to find any
scorpions
all of this dried brush
but don't use your fingers use a stick
or a blade
here we go danica got another scorpion
this is a more substantial one here
more meaty oh yeah he's a little fatter
yeah the thing is i've learned about
scorpions
and for years i always used to eat them
like this
they taste disgusting so full of like
this yellow kind of weird stuff and
really pungent to stays with you forever
but
if you cook them and you barbecue them
up
then it's perfect thank god for the fire
because that's going to make the
scorpion
taste just like char instead of
a scorpion here's your one
don't let it fall off
do you like to cook yeah i do i feel i'm
really
disappointing you really we should be
having nice rose and
oh yeah you're getting we should this is
like a downgrade i do feel for your life
so how do you keep so fit still i work
out all the time
i mean i work out exactly has that
helped you with injuries at all and
i think so and have you had bad injuries
and crashes
no that means you're a very very good
driver
well he's like you know you read never
never fight a man who
doesn't have a scratch on him did you
feel it was hard
harder for you going in as a as a girl
to that world
when he's when he's especially when he
went professional well i mean i don't
know if i thought it was harder as much
as i just
like ended up realizing it was harder
kind of thing i mean everything from
racing to um listening to
you know people say things about you to
bad days on the racetrack and how to
deal with them
you know you come back to the buzz and
i'd be like oh my god
36. i'm so bad you know and you just
have these really like flooding moments
of
like self-doubt and insecurity and um
yeah and so if i'm here long enough with
the scorpion i think it's all going to
be
charred and burnt in here should we go
for the school no i was just hoping that
would happen here you go you ready
no oh gross
okay it can't be that bad right you eat
them raw right
come on come on lead the way i love it
keep it out you got to finish it there
you go you got it you got it
scorpion
[Music]
you seem like you're savoring it is this
pretty bad i i can hear you say you're
like
good job
[Music]
you